now the Glasgow Darby is back celtic
will pay Rangers on Saturday in their
first league fixture for more than four
years it's one of the biggest games on
the planet and highly anticipated by
both sets of fans but would Scotland be
better off without it
the tribal passion that draws supporters
from all over the world say critics also
provides a release for the kind of
sectarian abuse that some believe
belongs in the 16th century and Scottish
police say that rates of domestic abuse
saw whenever the two teams meet well
let's discuss this joining me now is
Christine Summerville from the Rangers
fan group club 1872 and Angela Haggerty
who's the editor of common space and a
Celtic season ticket holder welcome to
both of you and to the Haggerty if I
could start with you we're going to see
then this weekend the resumption of one
of the fiercest rivalries in football
give us a sense first of all of how big
an event and olfin derby is for glasgow
it's absolutely huge immunise one to see
that there's there's not a great deal of
interest and the other fixtures in
Scottish football but when it comes to
the Derby tomorrow all eyes are on
Glasgow so it's a massive event it is a
huge thing it's something that even if
you're not a football supporter it's
very much in your diary you know that
it's going to happen a Christine
Summerville a massive event and one that
a lot of people will be looking forward
to hugely but some people might be
concerned because it is a fixture that
that can provoke some trouble or or
trouble results as a result of it well I
don't see any more trouble than any of
any other large gathering of people who
perhaps have had a few drinks and liked
to sing sing some songs and enjoy
themselves so I mean I'd be going to a
parent games since the 1970s and I've
never really seen any any real trouble
until Agassiz would you agree with that
do you think that this rivalry is any
more explosive than than other derbies
and other cities across the country yeah
absolutely I do because I think it's on
by a historical and thread of fettuccine
and racism that his weighted Society in
Scotland so I think that the whale all
eyes are on the 90 minutes of that game
it doesn't stop at 90 minutes actually
and there are a lot of repercussions for
the stuff it's not just the same as in
your garden and it's not just in songs
these songs means something specific in
Scotland and this is a societal problem
so I think this it's maybe a little
dismissive to see that it's more
definite for any other large Gardens I
think it's very different and for anyone
that gets caught up and and and a flexed
relate there's anyone that experiences
violence abuse any of that kind of stuff
and this is still quite common and a wet
the games as well it's not just about
the football you see this all over
social media Celtic and Rangers have
only met twice in the last four years
because of Rangers and financial
collapse and yet the rivalry is always
because of that so it's not just about
the spectra it's not just about it
gaming football it's a bit much more
than that in Scotland and I think that
we should acknowledge that Christie's
don't really notice you giving a slight
shake of your head at one point during
that what's your reaction there to what
Angela has he just says what well my
understanding was that I was coming on
am here to talk about that the game
itself everybody know with Angela has a
huge huge chip in her shoulder and a
huge agenda and quite frank you know I
do only want to talk about what's going
to happen on the pitch and who's going
to be the better team and who could win
I'm sure like just seem all that
interested in that she seems would
interest is in what me happen after the
game yes to be fair to Angela that's
what was was what I was asking her about
Christie some feel apologies if you
believe that this conversation was going
to take a different direction perhaps I
could ask you then about what you do
think will happen as far as the football
itself is concerned at the weekend then
well I can only tell you what I hope
will happen and that is the a replay
will obviously free when they're
fantastic and
if we don't then I'm still delighted and
blessed the club has made over the last
four years especially in the last year
and Christine Christine Summerville just
to pick up on some of the points that
have been made if you feel you clearly
feel that there isn't as much of an
issue as Angela Haggerty has thought
however both Rangers and Celtic of both
made effort to try and clamp down on on
some of the issues surrounding
sectarianism they've clamped down on but
on the singing of what's been considered
old partisans songs for example have you
noticed those changes having any impact
frankly no I think there was a time when
we we didn't know we could kill their
song bakr al ittle bit and I just think
that has come back recently but I'm
afraid that i doing i doing a few songs
this has been necessarily offense of
andrew hawk Hagerty what what do you say
to that I mean what difference do you
think that these songs can make and what
efforts do you think are being made be
by the club's but also beyond that by
other authorities to try to reduce any
tension well it's a massively
controversial issue in sport when
because they're sinking public got and
the offensive behavior at football and
threatened communications act and a
couple of years ago as a result of
trouble at all term games unless there's
an attempt to try and curb some of that
I can't pin down on the songs though a
lot of fantasy that that's preaches
freedom of expression they're very angry
about it we think it's about confident
on political songs as well as songs that
make ugly sisters athenian content and
them and so as a controversial one that
i have there are a team accessible is it
some club label to stamp them out many
people feel the clubs do not go further
and often that becker punishment should
take place to the clubs rather than the
fines individually and but i think what
these songs do you know some of them are
very offensive and they it can have an
effect on on the intended victims if you
like and so i think what we do is to
carry on
this rivalry and it's more than just a
rivalry and I think that it hinders
attempts to try and join two communities
that have for decades have been complete
loggerheads with one another I think
that the existence of the songs can be a
hindrance to that however there is in
the you know police authorities novels
kinds of things to try and stamp that it
seems to only make it worse the fans
tend to get defensive about that stuff I
think what you need to do is you need to
go down the road of Education you need
to try and get used to minute you
speaking to each other and that
ultimately it's a long game but
ultimately I think that's the only way
you're going to start to have an impact
on the transformed and Christine song
fell a last thought for you ahead of
this big game nervous excited I hope we
do well like to see us win I'll accept
to draw but as long as it's a good
performance and pleading a good spirit
then that's that's pain for me okay well
Christine Somerville and Angela Haggerty
thanks both very much indeed